I always thought of your life with your
dad being Carl Reiner who was a genius
and yet you pick this uh career you know
show business and you announced to the
family I want to be an actor at a young
age you say that
but people treat you like oh don't do
that yeah you know yeah don't be an
[__] because your father's so great
and then it's going to be nepotism yeah
yeah and but what I what I did was I
didn't take any money from him I didn't
take any advice or things so I knew I
was going to get that stuff I knew that
they were going to say the Sun the thing
and they still to this I mean we're
talking about it now yeah but I knew in
my head what I had done right so no
matter what they said I knew what the
truth of it when you were a little boy
your father didn't recognize you as
funny the guy who recognized you was
funny was Norman Lee Norman was a friend
of your dad that's exactly right I was
like nine eight years old I was playing
Jax with his daughter right explaining
the rules to her and apparently I made
Norman laugh he says to my father you
know what that kid he's really he's
really funny and my father said what are
you crazy that little that guy so he
didn't see it at all no no he I was a
brooding kid sitting in the corner I
mean that's not funny but did you have
issues growing up where but we're past
possibly you did have to see a
psychiatrist as a young man because it
is such a crazy world you grew up in I
it was tough I mean yeah intimidating
yeah it was intimidating and I used to
go down to the Van Dyke Show watch my
dad work with the actors and and I saw
how they worked with the cameras and how
he fixed the scripts and I studied all
that stuff and I wanted a competitive
with him I felt that way he didn't feel
away with me I felt like I wanted to be
I remember one time walking into his
office and sitting down now he wrote 20
25 scripts every year by and I sat
behind his desk and I look and I was
like you know 14 15 years old I said how
the hell am I going to do this how did
he do it was he alone when he wrote
These scripts yeah and you would walk in
and I guess he had a typewriter at that
point yeah and he'd sit there and just
bang it out like it was not like Mozart
bringing out a song yeah and I remember
as a kid you know I knew he was having
uh struggles with coming up with ideas
because he would wander into my room and
he would say anything interesting happen
to you anything going on here no baby
yeah so that I always knew he was a
little stuck yeah but what a process to
see yeah I mean what a crazy life
because when I think about that I like
in a way you're so competitive with
every boy is competitive with his father
you want to prove yourself to your
father and I would just be so filled
with angst I wouldn't please him I was
and I remember one time my dad and Mel
Brooks uh they were preparing to do the
Ed Sullivan Show uh and you only get
like six minutes and I came up with an
idea for a joke I was like 16 at the
time right and I came up with an idea
for a joke and I came down into the room
where they were and I said I think I
might have something and I'm just like
terrified you know because I had this
you're pitching and I'm pitching to my
dad and Mel Brooks and I had this joke
and they actually used it that was like
the greatest the greatest one that is
great and and I would think pitching to
those guys and then if you get smacked
down that's oh God you can't talk in the
room oh God I always imagine when your
dad and Steve Martin were working
together on the jerk right there's got
to be tremendous jealousy that's my
father I want that with him there was
and and and he you know he made four
pictures yes with with Steve Martin and
it was like he always talked about Steve
Martin as this you know that and I said
yes I had a different relationship with
my father but I would have loved to have
had what that was but you know it's of
course it's what it is you know because
Steve becomes like the favorite son yeah
he's like he's like yeah the son that
you wish you had who could do stick and
do all that yeah yeah it's tough it
really did you ever go to therapy for
that no what are you kidding me no I'm
kidding of course I do all the time this
is the the the time we're having right
here yeah this is the only time that I'm
not in therapy right this this moment
right here you go right back after this
oh yeah no no I'm I'm literally wall to
wall uh psychoanalysis yes
psychoanalysis therapy right yeah
because I think it's that pressure my
father's favorite son is Steve Martin
and not me yeah it's a constant yeah
there's a lot of competition and I can
tell you that it wasn't until and this
is now I'm in my mid to late 30s it
wasn't until I did Stand By Me that I
started feeling myself and I said okay
I'm carved I mean a long long time it
took me to start to carve out my own
identity yes and I said okay here's a
movie
that has this humor to it but it also
has a lot of melancholy in it yes which
is a real extension of myself
foreign